a reach out cross over up and down
[Music]
let's get one thing straight girls
you're all amazing dancers who emote on
stage you guys are the og Dance Moms
crew for a reason and your many talents
speak for themselves but if there's one
thing America loves its competitions
which is why only three of you will make
it into Abby Lee Miller's lists of
favorite dancers but that doesn't mean
that the rest of you don't have what it
takes to make a big because let's face
it you're all stars and our books Abby
Lee Miller doesn't hold anything back
when she sees something she doesn't like
just ask Paige and Brooke Hyland but
there are a few dancers who continue to
amaze her watch until the end to find
out who made it into the top three
Paige Highland Paige didn't have it easy
on Dance Moms and that's now thanks to
Abby Lee Miller unlike many other girls
at the ALDC Paige was dancing as an
extracurricular and had no intention of
pursuing dance as a career that didn't
sit well with Abby who grooms dancers
for the spotlight Paige didn't have the
same drive the other girls had and it
showed on stage causing Abby to rip into
her for not having the same talents as
her sister Brooke being on Dance Moms
stripped Paige of her passion for
dancing and it's easy to see why Nia sue
when Abby doesn't like someone she makes
it known which is why Nia often felt
left out she was often placed at the
bottom of the pyramid because Abby
didn't see her as a competitive dancer
Abby continuously underestimated Nia
despite her showing some very clear
signs of stardom instead of helping Nia
perfect her choreography Abby shunter
and then picked on her for not excelling
Nia does it
execute the choreography the way we
hoped it would obviously Nia wasn't
Abby's favorite but that never stopped
Nia from becoming a fan favorite
Kendall Verdes
Abby Lee Miller had mixed feelings when
it came to Kendall on one hand Kendall
had the look of a dancer which is
something Abby has always valued but on
the other hand Kendall didn't always
receive high scores for her solos which
bothered Abby tremendously in Abby's
eyes Kendall was a safe dancer who
performed well in group dances but she
was far from being her favorite girl on
the show Abby often picked on Kendall
for needing extra time to perfect her
choreographies Brooke Hyland at one
point in time Brooke Hyland was one of
Abby's favorite dancers but somewhere
down the line
Brooke lost her passion for dance and it
started to show Brooke went from being
one of the most talented dancers at the
ALDC to one of the least dedicated
students of all time
Brooke loved to dance because she got to
wear pretty costumes while hanging out
with her friends but that just wasn't
enough for Abby which led to the Kelly
Abby fiasco F season for Jojo C wa Jojo
and Abby might have bumped heads on the
set of Dance Moms but they're still very
good friends to this day
Jojo wasn't one of Abby's top-rated
dancers but she brought personality and
drive to the dance floor
which caught Abby's attention Jo to
excel to jazz and hip hop numbers but
more often than not Jojo was at the
bottom of the pyramid but once in a blue
moon she made it to the top and Abby
couldn't stop herself from smiling from
ear-to-ear
Chloe Lucchese AK Chloe Lucchese AK was
one of the most gifted dancers on Dance
Moms unfortunately for her Abby didn't
like to give her compliments but despite
how she treated Chloe
Abby loved her and knew how special she
was problem was Abby and Christi were
constantly at each other's throats
and Abby took her frustrations out on
Chloe instead of rooting for her abby
grew annoyed whenever Chloe scored high
marks because she didn't feel as though
she'd earned her success which obviously
wasn't the case
Mackenzie Ziegler coming in at number
four is Mackenzie Ziegler who almost
made it into Abby's list of top three
dancers
Abby has always had a soft spot for
Kinsey after all she knew her since she
was a baby but that never stopped Abby
from criticizing her and comparing her
to Maddie Kinsey is a multi-talented
young woman she is a remarkable dancer
who made it to the top of the pyramid a
handful of times
Brynn run follow subscribe rise friend
run follow is one of Abby Lee Miller's
top three favorite dancers of all time
Abby was always amazed by Bryn's
technical abilities she even went as far
as to say that Bren was born to dance
Abby made it very clear that Brynn was
one of her favorite students when she
invited her to the People's Choice
Awards in season six
Kalani Hilliker we're not surprised that
Kalani is Abby's second favorite dancer
she has technical abilities at Abby's
other dancers found hard to grasp and in
Abby's eyes she looks like what a dancer
was supposed to look like a beloved
Kalani's for work she thought she had
great legs and feet she loved her
onstage presence and passions Maddie
Ziegler but Abby Lee Miller's favorite
student of all time will always be
Maddie Ziegler the one who got away
Maddie went above and beyond to be the
best she had a competitive edge that
Abby admired and she continuously found
herself at the top of the pyramid it's
hard to find answers as dedicated and
passionate as Maddie which is why she'll
always be number one in Abby's eyes
and beautiful with beautiful feet not
Fred Flintstone fluffy how would you
rank the cast of Dance Moms with Brynn
Kalani and Maddie be your top three
picks sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap subscribe to the things
and give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you again
soon
[Music]